anh ạ
à à
anh alo các bạn nghe thấy chưa ạ
anh
[âm nhạc]
alo Chào tất cả bạn
hôm nay có biết con sợ mẹ con muộn nữa à
cho mình hình như vừa rồi bị vừa thấy
cái vụ là nhớ giữ tím không biết thì bị
hack vậy Tự nhiên đổi ảnh bìa trong lão
hóa được mấy hôm nào học nước bụng đây
chưa tôi thì vừa rồi tôi soạn bài nó
cũng bị lắm
à à
Ừ chắc là nóc nhà của thầy hiệu trưởng
lại bị lại
12 tháng mấy rồi
em còn nóc nhà tôi đang định khách đôi
hàng Bia của tôi
ừ ừ
Ừ ok thì hôm nay mình xin phép tâm sự
một tí tâm sự về
tốt nhất là như mình từng nói đó là con
gà ấy được thích kiểu
và đương nhiên thì con gái không phải
bảo là
ẩm thực thực dụng các tự thứ mình sẽ chỉ
nói là con gái thực tế hơn con trai
10 lời chúc tết con trai khá nhiều con
trai đương nhiên họ có mơ mộng nhé học
rất là mơ mộng nhưng mà họ vẫn kiểu nghĩ
cho tương lai theo kiểu là nghĩ về việc
là
nên lấy chồng như thế nào rồi kìa một
phần là do cái
khi cài đặt Thủ Xã hội nó kiểu bây giờ
nó kìa Thế là kiểu con gái phải lấy
chồng bây giờ sẽ bị ảnh hưởng rất nhiều
chi phối bởi Gia Đình Nhà chồng mỗi
người trong nên làm ra được con gái rất
cần người mà cặp thấy họ tin tưởng họ
cảm thấy có tương tương lai thì họ mới
thiệu
nghĩ cái thứ thứ
Vì thế nên là cái vụ mà Nhiều người bảo
là không thích cái kiểu chỉ yêu con trai
nhiều tiền lại cứ tưởng thứ thật ra là
nó lửa đúng nửa say
Ồ vậy à
Ừ đúng ở đây là việc là con ngại đứng
yên thực tế thấy rõ ràng mấy cái ông có
gì trong tay xong rồi ông chẳng nói gì
trong tay thôi nha nó sự so sánh rối
loạn
là tôi tôi cũng sẽ chọn bạn gái vừa xinh
vừa giàu so với bạn chỉ bình thường mà
không giấu tôi tôi sẽ làm để đấy Đang
đang nói qua về thế không nói qua tính
cách nhé
anh Bởi vì lúc đầu họ mới quen ông thì
làm sao họ biết là tính cách của ông nhà
họ sẽ nhìn vào cái gì họ nhìn và những
cái kiểu
thì đấy Đấy cái tôi đã định nói nó là
cái chí của ông thường anh gọi chị tiến
thủ
ông chủ nhật không Tôi tôi theo dõi kể
Tết tiếng Việt giàu đẹp trong ngoài nó
kiểu
từ thiên hạ nó đăng phải cái bài nào
kiểu thực ra từ trước đến nay các bạn
dùng sai chính tả rồi vẫn Vâng ra mới gì
đó xảy ra với Thôi mất dần cái niệm
chính tả đúng hay sai rồi
nhưng đại khái thế chứ tốn thủng như tôi
đang đang hình dung ấy thì nó sẽ ra
kiểu có muốn cầu tiến không muốn kiểu
dạng và kiểu dẫn chân lại chỗ nào ạ luôn
muốn mình tiến bộ lên các thứ thứ thì
cái việc con gái thì chị con trai còn gì
nữa tụi nó sẽ phù hợp theo kiểu là kể cả
sao dù ông không có gì trong tay thì ra
ông còn được biết phấn đấu xong những
điều không ghi trong tay không còn là nó
bỏ hôm nay con mà tự cái thành ra là con
gái không thích mấy cái thể loại đấy lắm
Trừ khi bạn nào thích kiểu thích thích
hẳn có vài bạn thì ra là cũng hơi Dịu lý
bạn đây cũng thích kiểu thay đổi được
một con người ở đó nếu bạn đấy là trong
trường hợp khi hai người quen nhau lâu
rồi Giả sử bạn kia thấy được không ai có
thể thay đổi được một Thay đổi hôm đấy
chứ không phải tự nhiên mới quen Tự
nhiên thấy ông này xấu vãi chưởng Đệ Nhị
đập đầu vào Thế thì điên loạn sẽ điên
mất
ừ ừ
nghe lời chúc là Kiều Ở mình từng mình
từng Không có gì giống tay theo kiểu rất
là nghèo mình để cũng đã từng hẹn hò với
các bạn nữ khá nhiều thế Mình khẳng định
được các bạn lấy nó không Không đến nỗi
là kiểu yêu cầu mình phải giàu có hay
các sư Xứ
ở đây là mấy ông Nếu mà tôi Tôi đang nói
với mấy ông ấy Nghĩa là mấy hôm ra khi
nào mà đang chỗ nghĩa chuyện hẹn hò tình
cảm có thứ cho tôi tôi thấy ở ra là tuổi
tuổi kiểu sinh viên học sinh ở này thì
ra vẫn nên có một cái mối tình trong cái
khoảng thời gian này bởi vì nó vẫn còn
ít thực dụng nó thực tế một tí nón còn
theo kiểu là
khi tất cả cùng chia sẻ
hoàn cảnh với nhau thay vì kiểu thay vì
kiểu mấy mấy ông Khi mà đi làm rồi Mấy
ông bắt đầu có tí cầu phải liên quan đến
tiền bạc các thứ thứ thì thành ra là hẹn
hò đôi khi ở đó có liên quan mối quan hệ
cho con tiền bạc hơn
vì nó không còn thực sự là tình cảm
trong sáng nữa
ừ ừ
Ừ đúng rồi tôi tôi từ một thân tôi từng
nói qua rồi mà Từng Hẹn Hò Dưới rất
nhiều
thành ra là Tôi không phải là một con
người chỉ biết lý thuyết suông đâu Thôi
thực hành rất nhưng rất nhiều rồi
à à
ra
tại đại khái thế tôi chia sẻ được vụ đấy
em bảo ông này mấy ông kiểu cảm thấy à
có động lực gì đó để mà
Em thử thử cả giá đấy thử cảm giác này
như tôi hôm trước có cũng ngon Nói về
cái vụ là béo phải có động lực để mà để
mà kiểu phát triển để tiến bộ hơn mà nó
bận
chị Thi động lực của mấy ông chính là
người yêu cũng là một động lực mà nước
vợ động lực khá to lớn đấy Cô đấy sẽ
khiến cho bạn phải thay đổi khá nhiều
người yêu cũ Tôi dậy rồi Nhiều vãi à
à à
a
tiếp theo nói về đỏ đen Ờ quan điểm của
mình mình là một con người ạ sống về lý
trí khá nhiều dáng hơn rất là kiểu tính
đã trường hợp các thứ thứ
nhà
mình gần nhau mình sẽ ít khi bị choáng
bởi vì à
sau khi bị sốc bởi vì mình đã tình hình
như là mới dồi và thế nên là bởi vì mình
tính các trường hợp mà mình thử mình
nghĩ ra được và cách đối phó vấn đề đấy
rồi nên là mình ít khi nghĩ đến việc đen
đủ lắm Mình sẽ nghĩ được à Có thể mình
chưa thành niên đến chưa được đấy
tốt hơn là mình nghĩ việc mình đen theo
cơ nhiều ông gấu bờ tháng này đen để các
thứ thằng qua lỗi do mình thôi
Vì mình chưa nghĩ việc bị đen Cái gì cả
mình chưa nói cô đen quá hay vân vân lại
lại thế đưa nhiên mình cũng nghĩ việc là
mình may mắn Mình thường hay nói có rất
nhiều rất nhiều yếu tố may mắn xảy ra
khiến cho mình đừng như bây giờ
cho
ví dụ Giả sử là nếu mà tôi mà xông vào
triều tiên con beauty thì chắc chắn có
thể thao không lời nhưng bây giờ nếu mà
tôi không kết bạn với cái ông mà học
khác lớp của tôi để ông ấy chia sẻ bài
của utyt thì chưa chắc tôi đã như bây
giờ vân vân đó bạn
em thậm chí là mình chưa biết mình kể
các bạn với cái vụ là mình à
từ hồi cấp 2 mình ở từng suýt trúng xổ
số 1 triệu đâu ở bên Mỹ mình nó tấm séc
thể bên này nhưng mà chẳng qua là tôi
nghe chưa đủ tuổi và cũng như ghi địa
chỉ mình ghi sử là 7 A3 không được nhận
Đây của hồi đấy một triệu đô là 16 tỷ
đấy à
cho mình mình không không may mà mình
mình cảm thấy may khi mà không nhận được
rồi đấy theo kiểu là có khi lúc đấy tôi
thành con người khác Xong rồi bây giờ
rồi Có khi là tôi thành là kiểu
ờ ờ kiểu dạng và
Anh có thể làm bố mẹ sẽ Tống Sang đi du
học nước ngoài để mà học về tài chính
chứ không phải học về được truyền kiểu
gì thế để mà học cách tiêu tiền rồi thế
bởi mỗi thằng lớp 7 thì gần đầy tiền nắm
tay nó không học hành gì nữa bỏ học mất
rồi Thế à
em có rất nhiều bước ngoặt trong cuộc
đời mấy ông đôi khi phải nghĩ lại những
cái bước ngoặt trong cuộc đời của ông và
mấy ông không không nên kiểu dạng là hối
hận vì một cái gì đó tôi trả giờ hối hận
cái gì đó trong quá khứ Mọi mình sẽ hiểu
à
cho
mình mình sẽ cậu lấy nó là bài học hay
là cái gì đó may mắn kiểu thế chứ không
coi nó mới sợ đen đủi gì cả cho tôi ít
khi hối hận gì đó
cho ví dụ kể cả tùy từng bị tai nạn các
thứ thứ nhưng mà chính vì sau cái vụ tai
nạn đấy tội nhận ra được nhiều điều hay
trân trọng và nhiều điều hơn Hãy cởi hết
à
hệ thống nhà tôi mua con máy này chẳng
ăn mày 38 củ này do cùi bắp này cứ máy
nóng lên là bị trêu chết Cá thứ tôi bây
giờ tôi rút kinh nghiệm và kiểu phải mua
mua hàng chính hãng mua hàng có vào hàng
các thứ đặt bìa những đôi định công nghệ
điện tử Thế là hôm qua tôi vừa mới đi
tìm lách khỏi đây nhưng mà săn lách vào
đây tìm mua con máy lọc nước máy là
không khí tôi phải tìm đúng chính hãng
và cũng như là hoặc là các cửa hàng to
uy tín thì tôi mới mua tôi không ham
mình ấy kiểu mấy cái trang hiểu trong nó
kiểu dạng vào trong có vẻ làn da sốc đấy
nếu mà dùng nói chung chẳng tin tưởng
với cả cái kiểu hết ế à à
Ê mấy ông cũng nên cân nhắc nhở vụ mua
máy lọc nước máy lọc không khí sớm đi
xung quanh chúng ta đang Ôi nhớ lắm nếu
không biết tôi đã từng sống ở phố Cổ
nghe về rất xa Nhưng thực ra là ở chỗ
đấy ẩm thấp và
Hà Nội chùa tệ tệ kinh khủng Các bạn cứ
hình dung lại cái nhà vệ sinh công cộng
ở ngoài công cộng nó như thế nào Nhà tôi
có nhà tù cả cái xóm nhà tôi dùng chung
với nhà vệ sinh công cộng nó cũng như
thế
Khi sản nhà trong phố cổ thì máy tí cái
thứ ẩm thấp nằm trên gác xép nó hư rồi
cứ nhớ lại thấy sợ đấy thì tôi tưởng
sống và môi trường như thế thôi hình
dung rõ việc là
cái không khí ô nhiễm mọi thứ hôi nhiễm
sẽ ảnh hưởng như thế nào
ở đáy và tội cảm thấy may mắn đi xa bây
giờ vẫn còn tỉnh táo không bị dấu hiệu
gì cả anh chỉ có phổi hơi bị yếu một tí
thôi ạ
anh ở đấy và tiếp về cuối thì vừa rồi
mình có nói qua lại việc làm mọi thứ do
mình tính toán quyết định thế nên là
mình thừa Mẹ không tin hẳn vào duyên số
lắm
Mình mình yêu nghĩa là mình cũng nghĩ
được là chúng ta phải có một cách gì đó
tinh con vô tình mà khiến gặp được nhau
như thế phấn Vân đó nhọn như là tôi
không tin là số phận mình do nó được
định sẵn có nhiều cái kiểu bói tử vi hay
bói bói gì đó tôi trả lời tin được
dù người ta nói có thể có thể có vẻ rất
hợp lý và rất nghe mày giữa hai người ta
bỏ cái tôi là một con người đào hoa này
bây sau dầu Đấy đấy nghe Nghe hấp dẫn
không Ông xong rồi bị ông nghe thấy
giọng thích được không Anh nên tôi có
tin đâu Tôi không chờ tin mà bỏ toán
không tin vào cái
tủ sách tử vi cuộc sống mình do mình
quyết định không phải là người thật
không phải trọn đời ghi là là năm nay
bạn sẽ cưới vợ và tôi sẽ cưới vợ 2 năm
nay bạn sẽ mất thì thì ông kiểu rượu sẽ
mất trong năm này không đúng
em năm nay bạn sẽ giàu thế nên là bạn cứ
ăn chơi thoải mái đi thôi đừng phát năm
đấy bạn giàu có không làm gì có chuyện
đấy rồi đúng không ạ Thế nên là mình
không tin là những cái đấy
Em gọi thử vẫn là do mình quyết định và
học lập trình ngày thở ra đấy cái lợi
cái tư duy như thế các bạn khiến cho các
bạn là học lập trình nghề được gọi là
phải có mua gì lôgic và không có gì mày
rồi Không có gì đỏ đen mọi thứ đều phải
cậu tính toán cẩn thận để mà ra được
giải quyết được vấn đề đó bạn
Ừ Ok bây giờ vừa đúng lúc hết rồi ạ Mình
sang trả lời các hỏi nha
Mỹ
[âm nhạc]
Tâm Linh à tâm linh là một thứ gì đó
không giải thích được mình tin nó có
thật nhưng mà
cơ bản nhưng mà mình sẽ không
mình mình cũng tìm hiểu Vì nó hạ khá
nhiều nhưng mà ý máy mình sẽ thường anh
hạn chế rồi nó vừa thừa những cây thử
đấy mình nghĩa tò mò nhiều lại không tốt
ok đầu tiên à Hôm trước của tôi ra bài
tập về hai bài 2 lần bài tập về sơ đồ
khối thuật toán Nếu mấy ông để ý thì ca
ở tôi chưa dậy rồi đấy thôi muốn cho bé
uống làm qua đã và hôm nay tôi sẽ dạy
con mày thử cá học TP thì ra khá nhanh
kiến thức qua mạng làm lắp
tạm thời Thế tôi đang dạy các bạn từng
bước từng bước mà không ạ sau đó thì còn
thời gian tôi sẽ dậy mình Ông ấy sơ đồ
khối thuật toán và chữa bay hôm trước
a tiếp theo
dự đoán xịn có giới thiệu công việc
không thì nếu mà bạn ở chưa biết thì là
tôi sẽ bảo là mày ông sẽ có một cái đồ
án làm và bảo vệ vợ và sẽ làm theo cặp
thì cho buổi tí tôi cũng sẽ làm một cái
phom và gửi các bạn thì các bạn điền
điền thông tin các thứ thú để mà tôi sẽ
chạy ra luôn ghép cặp cho mấy ông này
mấy ông chung một cái đồ à chung cũng
muốn nhóm mày làm đồ án
và đặc biệt là nên ghét sớm để mấy ông
kiểu có động lực thúc nhau ai cũng có
nên có trách nhiệm tinh thần làm việc
theo nhóm nó gọn kiểu dạng và ông này
thấy ông kia học hành trình mảnh lại gì
đó
anh gọi thì mèo ông sẽ nhắc nhở nhau chứ
tôi ở đây tôi không ngờ nhắc tất cả mấy
ông
bà và cái vụ bảo vệ đồ án thì sẽ
như tôi đã nói thì sẽ cố Mời tất cả các
thầy để mà tham gia để phản biện ném đá
mấy ông để mấy ông tiểu bảo vệ được
thành công thì sẽ chắn là thứ nhất ở mấy
ông cảm thấy thỏa mãn này làm đã thứ hai
là cậu sẽ tự thấy mình trưởng thành hơn
so với ngay bây giờ ngay bây giờ đây nè
Bây giờ là lúc là mấy ông mới bắt đầu
học so với thời đấy nếu không sẽ thấy ở
cậu nó sẽ khác xa như thế nào đến như là
như tôi nói là sau cái khóa này Thực ra
mấy ông vẫn chưa đi làm được đâu bởi vì
tất cả mấy trẻ cơ bản đồng loại méo đi
làm mình mới chỉ đi tập vậy thôi và vẫn
phải học hỏi thêm thì béo Nhưng mà mấy
ông sẽ cân nhắc mình việc là có thể
thiện treo khóa sau 20 Hóa ở trên sau
hơn và khóa đấy sẽ mới mới là thứ mà dậy
những cái thứ mà béo có thể đi làm được
luôn
thì cái vụ đồ ăn xịn có giới thiệu công
việc không thì thực ra như mình đã nói
là mình còn bây giờ có rất nhiều bên
đang hỏi mình mình một lực thậm giữa
công ty mình đang thiếu một lực nhưng mà
yêu mình như mình vừa nói luôn đó là
kiểu các bạn Nếu mà đi tập sớm như thế
thì các bạn vẫn phải học Lỡ bài học rất
nhiều và
A và kiểu dáng không phải công ty nào nó
cũng sẽ đào tạo các bạn đồn các bạn đôi
khi sẽ bị là nó cái mà vào một công ty ở
đó mà cảm thấy họ bơ họ họ bơ mình với
việc họ mà không đào tạo ổn họ sẽ kiểu
giao trong một đống tài liệu rồi mẹ mấy
ông tự Ngồi đấy mà đọc sau quan thậm chí
ở vẫn giao cho ông việc mà Việc đấy ông
chưa biết làm nhẹ ạ ông sẽ bị phạt Nếu
hiểu tôi không nên là mấy ông sẽ phải
cân nhắc Đã đó là mấy ông phải làm làm
đồ án xong mày không cảm thấy trình độ
của mấy ông đã đủ đã đủ chưa không nhỉ
vẫn phải làm thêm một cái đồ ăn nữa đúng
không này có thực sự ngon hẳn đã
mấy ông bây giờ cứ tính đi bây giờ học
hết cái pp khóa này chắc là cũng là ba
hàng nữa thôi
2013 thằng chuyên sâu nữa
nửa năm học nửa năm ở trên Thường mấy nó
có khi ở chưa bằng học nửa năm của tôi
cái đấy tôi khẳng định được thì mấy ông
đợi được đến thời gian này em ấy không
đi làm vẫn đường mà đúng loạn nghĩa là
trước Hè năm sau sẽ khẳng định được là
trước hai năm sau trước 11 tháng 6 này ạ
Hãy
ừ ừ
a tiếp theo có nên nghiên cứu khoa học
hay không
cứ nghiên cứu khoa học này chắc là liên
quan đến kiểu sống như mình cái kiểu làm
bài luận hay cái gì gió ở bên đại học
tôi khuyên mấy ông là kiểu
với bên lập trình này thì thấy ta chúng
ta không cần biết lý thuyết quá
à à
cho
nên nên là kiểu 0000 lên không nên kiểu
tìm hiểu sâu quá vì lí thuyết làm gì cả
đấy tôi khuyên như thế còn nếu mày Ông
lại muốn học lên thạc sỹ hai mấy ông
muốn có một cái gì đó kiểu dạng lại Ok
chứng chỉ hãy chứng nhận gì đó
À thì ra tôi vẫn khuyên như thế nhá về
thực sự thì đi lại đi Chiều khi ông đi
đấu thầu hoặc cả ông trời muốn khoe
khoang gì đó thôi không thì thường là
người ta nhìn vào trình độ của ông kinh
nghiệm thực tế hơn
à mình mình mình hiểu cái nghiên cứu
khoa học và làm một cái đồ án nhưng mà
nó sẽ là chỉ là một cái nghiên cứu thôi
Có cái lý thuyết thôi lần như thế cho
bên đại học chính quy mình biết mà bên
đại học Bách khoa mình thấy có rất nhiều
bạn làm xong thì đề tài nghiên cứu các
thứ thứ song Thực ra nó cũng ra gì ấy nó
cũng hiểu đương nhiên là học không lời
Thừa cả Nổi Loạn các bạn học sau là tốt
nhưng mà cũng Trọng đây
Anh khoe cái đấy cho bên là
trừ khi các bạn xin vào những ngành
chuyên sâu về lí thuyết giống như là
Toán y cá thứ thì may ra họ cần cầm nếu
mà các bạn vào làm bác em kiểu Làm lập
trình viên như bình thường như này người
ta đòi hỏi các bạn phải thực hành người
ta không đòi hỏi với Nếu thuộc tá xịn
như là
nhà báo thực sự là mấy ông tìm hiểu sâu
á Tôi thề mấy cái ông tìm hiểu sâu mãi
cứ bị máy móc còn gì một bài toán đơn
giản mà Mấy ông cứ phức tạp lên thành ra
là tôi thôi bị dị ứng mấy kiểu này lắm
Tôi là con người từ bên nghề ra mà anh
hơi bị sợ rồi đấy
ờ ờ tiếp theo là espn interactions 2 là
ờ
cho mình mình sẽ Đề cập về cái event gas
này tất cả một kiểu hình thức hack mà
chắc là vậy
ạ sau khóa này hỏi thậm chí hôm bảo vệ
đoán Tôi sẽ thử hỏi mấy ông người cái
đây xem
xem web rồi mày ông có bị dính mấy cái
lỗi hết khủng đã từ từ không Ừ chắc À
cái này tôi sẽ dậy Sao lâu vậy
anh ở Lưu kiểu dữ liệu ảnh trong Fe ở
trong buổi sau mình sẽ chỉ đây tìm heo
có bạn hỏi là họ trước bạn ấy muốn họ
trước pp thì học ở đâu ngoài đang live
school thì thơ ca Hồi trước mình có thử
cho sinh viên mình ôn thì ổn ở trên à
cốt
code academy mình mình có chỉ là sinh
viên lên đấy mà có làm trước một vài cái
kiểu bài tập các thứ
có academy
tại các bạn thể tham khảo trên trang đấy
Thực ra là mình cũng sẽ giao các bạn mỹ
bài tập
Nếu thế có cả một tí nâng cao một tí đi
để cho các bạn luôn có thời gian đủ để
mà
Ừ nếu mà bạn nào thừa thì ra đấy vẫn có
thể có thứ để mà làm đi học được ạ
Ừ
mình đang dạy hướng đến là kiểu phù hợp
cho bạn nào đang học ngành khác cũng có
thể học được anh ra cậu cũng tương đối
chậm mà cũng trong nồi ít bài tập thôi
chứ nhiều bài quá thì nó cũng khá nhiều
buổi dạy quá thì đã nó không ổn lắm
a tiếp theo là có bạn hỏi về kiểu Khi
nào thử lai cốt để mà viết một cái tiện
ích gì đó giống như thế Tôi từng viết là
gái xinh chọn lọc thành lại chả là tôi
sẽ dạy cái này sau dậy sau
tôi cái Tôi không hứa được cái này lúc
nào chả phải tùy cảm hứng nữa và tùy
thời gian xem mà rảnh hay bận nữa
t-ara mà chắc mình sẽ mình sẽ chốt lại
lần cuối về việc là trong khóa này mình
sẽ dạy những cái gì và khóa sau mình sẽ
dậy những cái gì để cho những bạn nào
quan tâm nhé trong khóa này là pp cụ Cơ
bản nó gọn và web cơ bản
đây web cơ bản thì mình sẽ dạy hát em
lâu rồi này sẽ hết rồi này ra Switch rồi
đây nếu mà chỉ để làm bếp này
pp này
cái video này à
ở những cái này thì à p chỉ đầy đủ tính
năng CRD để xem thêm sửa xóa
xin đăng nhập Cookie và
a a flash file hay bạn lại phải như thế
mình sẽ không dạy về Ok không thể mvc
thống khóa này mai que thì sẽ chỉ là
cũng lại bml là là Insert update bị
Delete phải cô đơn giản đây QL cũng thế
là câu C của Ngoạ những con đơn giản
thôi mình sẽ không hẳn là dạy các bạn về
Goodbye không không không có Goodbye
không có do gì cả mấy
A và trong gia Swift này mình cũng sẽ
không dậy thêm chèn thêm gj0 chèn thêm
Facebook hay thư viện gì cả đấy đều có
bạn đang nghĩa là web cơ bản này sẽ như
thế còn khóa sau sẽ web chuyên sâu à
linh cảm được chứ Dậu được kìa Cái cái
sau là đúng Hát Việt thật thì ngoài mấy
cái mình đã dậy thì mình sẽ dạy thêm về
level là Facebook của Facebook của TP đó
bây giờ ra quyết định hành giữa ổn nhớ
là gladio này thì mình sẽ chỉ dậy một
cách cơ bản
Ừ chứ không phải là dùng những cái hàm
có sẵn của Lara để mà cốt nhanh mình sẽ
dạy các bạn về quê do và cậu cốt thuần
là nhiều để mà mình sẽ dạy chuyên sâu và
cả bên hẹn axwell nữa vẫn là mái quelle
nhưng là này nasware nó sẽ là có thể roi
và Seung Ri a
khi được ạ
Các tiểu thư để mặc và đương nhiên là sẽ
có Goodbye vậy mà thùng thống kê làm bài
toán thống kê các thứ thứ đấy và vectơ
sau này còn sẽ còn dậy sâu hơn về việc
là
bài toán xử lý cần phải như thế nào chứ
không phải chỉ đơn giản là hiển thị ra
hãy các thứ Nói chung là
các bạn khi mà các bạn học cái này có
bạn mình sẽ cảm thấy là kẹo thật sự là
học cái này xong các bạn thấy bất kỳ cái
trong web nào Bây giờ các bạn cũng hình
dung được cái cái cách làm của nó như
thế nào không phải làm lại được hành
trang web kiểu như nó nhưng mà hoàn toàn
có thể biết được bọn nó làm như thế nào
làm lại được thì vẫn làm được thôi để
trải qua nó áp dụng nhiều công nghệ cao
siêu Hóa thì mình sẽ
vụ tấn công nhiều để mà làm được lại như
đó
Ừ nhưng mà học xong cái khóa sau mình
vẫn khẳng định là bất kỳ cái gì thì các
bạn nhìn vào các bạn sẽ nhìn thấy đầy lỗ
họng đầy những cái thú mà nó sơ sài nó
thiếu nó đểu và các bạn hoàn toàn thấy
mình có thể làm được một cái tương tự
cái cái khóa sau sẽ như thế Thế các bạn
đi làm được rồi Đúng đoạn đi làm được
Chỉ cần thế thôi bạn đúng không ạ ạ
xe tải mình mình đã vừa trả lời hết một
là có hỏi các thứ các bạn thắc mắc gì cứ
bình luận nhé em ohh còn thêm một câu
nữa bạn có bạn vừa khỏi luôn đó là mình
cài cái chim Cài những cái gì Sao sắp
với tách thì mình đã từng đi ở trên Blog
của mình rồi nhá
mình cái hiện tại cái này để cho nó kiểu
hiển thị ra trông nó đẹp cũng như là
cũng như là kiểu nó gợi ý các thứ
à à
ở đâu loạn thì mình mình sẽ
thì các bạn thấy giao diện nó sẽ đẹp hơn
tí ghép cốt bằng pp
[âm nhạc]
thôi bắt đầu buổi hôm nay nhé bố mẹ mình
sẽ dạy các bạn với cái gì
Ờ Ờ mình sẽ dạy các bạn về phom được ạ
bản chất là mình sẽ có một cái phone sau
đó điền thông tin sau đó thì mình sẽ in
ra những thông tin mình đã Điên cái rất
cơ bản như thế
Anh hiểu sẽ như thế nào trước tiên à tôi
xóa tên là đi tôi đợi nó tên thằn Phone
này một cái pho mày không gọi E
I
know kahat đồng loại localhost to school
này
đó sẽ ra cái phone này cứ đầu đứng nhờ
đang không có gì không ạ bây giờ sử điền
thông tin cá nhân đi tên này
thì bây giờ các bạn sẽ thấy tác dụng của
nêm này mình sẽ cho Đây là tên đây
mình sẽ tạm bỏ qua dùng ra suýt va date
nhá Mình chỉ làm đơn giản theo cậu là
pho mình Điền xong các thứ thứ thì mình
in lại những này mình đã Điền thì họ sẽ
như thế nào ở đây là ngày sinh rồi ạ
Ừ
Thì quy tắc đặt nêm này thì giống như
mọi khi mình hay bảo đó là mình nên dùng
gạch mình thư da trong này có thể có thể
dùng nhiều cách có thể ghi có dấu nhưng
mà không ai làm thế cả bởi vì tí mình sẽ
phải lấy lại cái này nên là mình khuyên
các bạn nên là kiểu ghi kiểu dạng là
gạch dừa nhé hay là kiểu con mặt bàn
không ạ thường mà mình thích code pp
mình hỏi anh Dũng bày dứa như thế này
với ngôn ngữ khác thì người lại thích
kiểu quán lạ bà hơn
thì nghèo
email mật khẩu nhưng mình cứ để mật khẩu
- cho bạn
các bạn tí các bạn sẽ hiểu tại sao mình
đang cho điền mày cái thông tin này ở
đây sẽ là giới tính đúng không ạ giới
tính
Ừ vậy thôi tạm nhà trước bạ tạm ngày
trước cứ làm dần dần đã
đăng ký ạ
oke tự động viên này
Ừ
thôi cái vào ở ẩn danh đi tôi sẽ mở và
ẩn danh này nó không tự động Điền ừ
ở
đó à
Anh
Đài Giả sử Trong trường hợp như thế này
chỉ tôi điền tên của tao hỏi nó Hạ Long
chẳng hạn thường ngày sinh này mật khẩu
123 như thế này Sơn tôi là đăng ký nếu
không thấy là béo có để ý kĩ là trên
thanh địa chỉ của tôi đề nó đã truyền
đúng cái một tôi đã Điền ở trong form để
hai địa chỉ loạn thực À đây Đây là kiểu
đẩy 7 dữ liệu và đầy dữ liệu kiểu này
thì nó sẽ gọi là mấy thớt là ghét rất là
đẩy hết nên anh bị chìm thực là thường ở
chẳng bây giờ người ta không dùng mải
miết ghét này để mà đẩy thông tin trong
form
mà chúng ta sẽ
mà sẽ dùng cái thớt post Nhưng mà mình
cứ để mua qua mấy thứ ghét trước đã thì
mình sẽ ghi made là ghét trước này và
mình muốn đẩy xa cái Khoai khác thì ghi
lại thông tin mà đã nhập Ừ
thì mình sẽ là sẽ có khái niệm mà Action
mình sẽ nhảy một cái file ở đó là sử
file này sẽ là file để mà xử lý in ra là
bạn mình sẽ đặt tên nó là cố xét và xử
lý đi
thì tiếng Anh Tím Nếu làm quen với việc
để tiếng Anh nữa chỗ để tiếng Việt và
nhiều trong nó cứ nấm dân của gì đây
à à
A và file này giả sử của mình chỉ đơn
giản là muốn in ra thôi lấy cái gì mình
đã ngập rồi in ra đúng vai mình đã nghỉ
thì đây nếu mà chỉ có mỗi thế mà không
có gì hết pin màu nào thì ông có thể
khái niệm của nhà ở
thì các bạn phải là không có tí thẻ HTML
nào như bên này mà sẽ chị là mở thẻ Tt
là nó loạn sau đó thì tôi thường là tôi
sẽ xóa luôn cả cái đóng thẻ này Tại sao
bởi vì đợi Nếu mà file chỉ p thôi mà
không một tí có gì nữa thì mày ông có
thể xóa luôn cái thẻ đóng của thẻ pp để
nó tự động đó như ông Nếu nó không Tự
nếu mà ông mà để
ở đây để tôi dạy nha nếu file chỉ pp của
bọn mà
khi
đóng hè sau thẻ đóng có thửa khoảng
trống
hoặc ký tự
đôi khi sẽ lỗi sẽ gây lỗi lỗi là gì về
sau mình sẽ dạy các bạn Tại sao nó bị
lỗi đấy tay giả sử là thường là các bạn
sẽ nghĩ ra là thể pp có bao gồm Mở thẻ
và đóng thẻ nha nó tự nhiên vì sao tôi
có một dấu cách là đằng sau cháu cháu là
biết được là sau này có dấu cách vì nó
là cách mà nó sẽ nhìn được nó bạn và nó
sẽ đôi khi nó sẽ sinh các bạn cái lỗ ấy
nó lỗ không trắm
ừ ừ
Ừ thế thế này là tối khuya là nếu pha
chỉ p thì mình xóa luôn cả thể đóng cho
nó đi để nó tự động đóng cho mình một
tiếp theo là gì mình lấy lại những thông
tin mình đã nhập để mày ra không ạ thì
tôi sẽ Khái niệm và tên này bằng đôla
gạch dưới ghét sau đó thì ghi tên địa
ngay như này thì tất cả mấy ông đã lấy ý
tên từ cái ghét và lấy từ trên thanh địa
chỉ này và để nó ra là sự cái chỗ ở đây
là bạn đã nhập
tên cho ạ
tên là nha à trực tiếp xổ số Quảng Ngãi
D3 tôi xóa mấy cái chết hay bị chỉ đi
điện bộ chữ Long rồi chở bạn tôi không
nhập phải cái gì ở kia ấn mà Mấy ông
thấy ở trên thanh địa chỉ này tên ngày
sinh mật khẩu nó vẫn được truyền lên
nhưng mà nó đang ở trống và tên Sẽ Lau
bạn nhập tên làm ok rối loạn và bây giờ
mình sẽ lấy những cái thứ khác về thôi
họ mình sẽ mình sẽ ra sửa mình điền thêm
cả thông tin này
ấn vào các bạn thấy trên thành địa chỉ
nó được truyền Lên Kiểu như là thứ nhất
là Nguyễn ngày sinh với đấy thì như tôi
từng nói là người lập trình thì nó sẽ
luôn là năm tháng này đoạn ấy cái thử
Tôi đang định nói nghĩa là đôi khi ạ nếu
mà ông muốn in đang ngày tháng năm thì
Miễu ngoại phải format lại phải Định
dạng lại cái cái đấy còn không mày
thường là nó sẽ như thế này Ừ
cái tiện ích Tôi đang dùng này là edit
extension
And you are pro vậy ạ
ở đây
được ạ
để xem được cái trên thanh địa chỉ này
của mình mà đúng hạn và mật khẩu thì mấy
ông thầy ăn Nếu mà đẩy me hết lắm ghét
lên thì lộ hết mật khẩu như thế này đúng
ạ nếu không sẽ bảo là
em chẳng ai nhìn trên mực thánh địa chỉ
lắm đâu mà Có phải em dùng trên máy của
em mà sao thằng khác nhìn được trên anh
địa chỉ của em có gì đúng ạ nhưng mà
không ờ ờ
Ừ cái á á
em thấy khi mà người ta dùng chung mạng
với ông gần như là họ vẫn có thể dùng
cái phần mềm để mà bắt được gói mạng của
ông và ông đang truy cập đến trang web
nào trừ khi ông dùng VPN được bạn
thế nên là đấy à nhược điểm này ông dù
wi-fi chú ấy Hoặc là những cái Trang mà
là không phải là
https với cái Trang là http tay với đội
trang này chẳng hạn thì phê này thì khi
mà điền những cái thông tin trong form
nó sẽ không được mã hóa những thành ra
là ông mà Điền mật khẩu ở trong mấy cái
Trang đấy thì thì thằng nào mà dùng
chung mạng của ông nó vẫn thể bắt được
cái gói tin này của ông giống như ông
gửi thư ông gửi hư Để cái cái bưu điện
mình ạ trong thời gian mà cái Thư là
được gửi đến bưu điện thằng khác rồi bóc
ra xem được thư của ông đấy thế do nguy
hiểm
thế nên việc đầu tiên của mấy ông là mấy
ông phải đổi mến hết về kỹ thuật ghép
vào máy ông phải nội nói mới thức post
và và trong cách của ông lên là https
bây giờ nó sẽ mã hóa cái trong phòng của
ông đâu lận hiện tại miếu nó chạy lên
trình máy của ông thì không sao vì nó
local thì ông để ATP face được rồi nhưng
mà nhưng mà nếu mà cả ông ông đẩy cái
cốt này xanh là ra ngoài mấy ông Thuê
hẳn một cái Trang web domaine nào đó để
mèo chạy được cốt này thì bắt buộc cái
USB phải có ssl tất cả có https không
những người dùng Điền những cái gì và
trong cái cái for của ông là thằng khác
nó cũng thể biết được
em
đổi nó hàng mới thấp tốt này à
xe tải giờ sáng ngập lòng này chẳng hạn
như này
nếu không sẽ thấy nó báo lỗi Thủy thứ
nhất là nó không để 2 địa chỉ nữa nên là
cái ghét này nó không tìm thấy để chuyển
để mà lấy cái mà mình đã nhập thì nó nhờ
đổi ghép thành phó thôi rồi bọn mày ông
bắt buộc phải viết hoa như này nhá mày
Ông đừng có lười hiểu biết thường ngày
mà nghĩ rằng mà nó nó chạy nhá Không tôi
không phải tự nhiên tối Hưng với em biết
kiểu nghe đâu ạ và bắt buộc phải đúng
như thế này nhá Đấy thêm và khi mà ông
khi ông ấy Ông tải lại cha mày mà gửi
lại for đấy thì đối với mi thức post thì
nó luôn hỏi lại câu này béo cứ ăn con im
thôi cái nó sẽ gửi lại gửi lại phom và
đương nhiên là lần này vẫn lấy lại như
bình thường gọn chị ra buổi học hôm nay
có thể chị ngắn như này thôi như kiểu là
mấy ông sẽ lấy lấy
10 cái phom có một iPhone này rồi mấy
ông
ờ ờ lấy toàn bộ những cái đã điên trong
cái phone này mày in ra ngọn Nếu mà
trước trước khi mà kết thúc buổi học thì
đương như là mình sẽ còn thêm những cái
trường hợp ngoại lệ nữa những cái trường
hợp gì mình sẽ làm thêm ví dụ là giới
tính là ạ giới tính này ạ
thì mình cứ để nó thành mới thấy ghét
trước đi Tại sao bởi vì mình muốn đẩy
lên hai địa chỉ các bạn Hình dung là
trên anh địa chỉ nó thể truyền lên và
những gì nếu bạn hãy cứ để đó là mấy xét
lại nhé á
thế
giới tính này các bạn nhớ vụ Giới Tính
giới tính thì thật sự đây là nam này để
nữ này thì cả hai cái này bắt buộc thứ
nhất là nó radio đấy phép chọn một này
hay lại bắt buộc phải là cùng chung cái
nêm đấy nó chỉ chọn một với bọn kẻ nhớ
ai nam nữ này đúng bọn
nhà tôi tặng xóa cái này trước đây á gửi
tôi cho mấy ông dễ Hương Dung xem việc
là nếu với giới tính mà chọn kiểu như ai
thì nó sẽ đẩy cái gì để thay Nghị chị
nhé hiện đầu tiên cho không chọn cái gì
thì ấn vào này nếu thấy nó chẳng truyền
đi nên anh bị chỉ cả đúng rồi nó thành
hỏi chấm nhưng mà chẳng truyền thêm với
cả Bây giờ sửa kích vào cái này Truyền
đây này thì giới tính nó sẽ biến những
hiểu lại thì ngon cơ đúng ạ nghĩa là mấy
ông phải có hai trường hợp xảy ra là một
là không truyền lên cái gì cả hai là
giới tính bằng ngon và giúp của con
Ồ tôi thích vào cái này thì nó vẫn là
ngon đúng ạ thì mới ông sẽ thấy à
Ừ thế thì hơi sai làm sao mình biết được
là mình đã chọn giới tính nào đúng ạ đấy
Thì bây giờ mình có va luu cho nó riêng
kể Rio này mình bắt của Zalo nó ấy hiểu
mình đã chọn Cái gì là sự đền Nam này để
nữ ạ ạ
ừ ừ
[âm nhạc]
thế hả Không mình không Bôi đen đâu Mình
gần control control b là nó sẽ tự động
đã ký kết một dòng và ấn giữ phím enjoy
để sửa hai dòng cùng một lúc đấy ạ
nhà
mình có thể Bôi đen cả đoạn này rồi mình
trong Hyundai nó sẽ đáp pi kết cả cái
dòng ra dòng nữa Thôi
cái kiểu như này Bây giờ mình ấn lại nhé
đó lên giới tính là Nam đúng không Lại
đây vào đây dự tính cho nữ cây rồi lo
đấy tương tự thì phải chiếc bóp nhé và
tiếp theo nữa thì mình sẽ có là select
sẽ e captions
chị
đã sử lần này mình sẽ ở
sở thích đi
là Sunny có chân à
ở đây
a kinh dị này
chính hãng mà
người lớn tình cảm em ạ
kính Ai
đứng như là mấy ông sẽ phải cho nó cái
nêm được ngọn nên mà Sở thích đi
tôi bấm vào này thì trong trường hợp này
thì nó sẽ chuyển nếu mà nếu mà mệt ông
không có cái ba lô cho bé óc chân thì nó
sẽ lấy đúng cái chữ ở trong óc Trần đến
biến thành Peru như thế này Nhưng mà
thường là
khi người ta đôi khi không lấy được nha
người ta sẽ ghi thêm valeu cụ thể và cho
nó chân và value đôi khi nói chuyện một
hai thôi như tôi từng bảo giới tính mình
lưu chị ạ 0,1 Thôi thì cái một vài cái
này nóng thế và lu nó sẽ là số nô này
lưu nó nó ngắn hơn nó dễ hơn 1 là sẽ hứa
và kinh dị hay nó sẽ cứ là gì gì đó thay
vì hiểu lưu lại cả chữ toàn bộ như thế
này
à à
ờ ờ tiếp theo còn gì nữa nhỉ Đúng rồi
bây giờ giả sử là thật sự là mô tả bản
thân đi
mấy ông nhớ với khách Alo ạ ạ
Anh thích alo mình sẽ con lên với nó
là mô tả à
Em đang ở nhà mà lần này tôi sẽ cho hơn
một cái sớm à Thật sự là cuộc đời
I was bored đ
à à
Em
hãy cảm nhận không phải tôi nó nhắn tao
ví dụ
anh đăng ký
à à
ừ ừ
Ở nhà vẫn nhắn nhỉ Thế thôi cho xài hơn
thì tại sao tự nhiên tôi đang phải đề
cập vụ giải hơn về nó sẽ sai mà sẽ sinh
ra cái trường hợp này cái sinh ra trường
hợp và nếu mà ông để mấy thớt cả Ghét
thì khi mà điền cái gì đó dài quá Để em
hay địa chỉ họ sẽ bị bào Cái lỗi này đó
là Thanh địa chỉ của ông là quá tải khóa
lớn cái thành ra là cậu mấy ông sẽ không
phù hợp cho việc điền trong phom người
thương là ghét ạ à mà Mấy ông lên đội nó
mới rất là top đấy gần nhất
Ừ thứ hai nữa là nó còn sẽ sinh năm một
cái kiểu như này Đây đây Tôi cho ông
thêm một ví dụ nữa
là sự bây giờ trọ ảnh đi chọn hàng cá
nhân này
in cút file đúng loại nên mà ảnh gọi
Cho xem cái ảnh Bút Chì đây bạn đăng ký
đấy không thấy đẩy lên hai địa chỉ lại
là tên của cái ảnh nó không đúng
Ừ kiểu như này Nếu không thể in được ra
cái ảnh đâu
khi mà bản chất là mấy ông phải đẩy
trong mấy thất riêng và đẩy ảnh nhá Khi
lại đây đẩy file trong phom thì bắt buộc
phải có hai yếu tố thứ nhất một là mấy
thớt là pet thứ hai nó sẽ phải mã hóa mã
hóa nữa lợn mã hóa nó sẽ là à
cô diện and clip nhờ không làm mẹ andres
với gì đó Tôi không nhớ chính xác rồi
nhưng cha cái ra mà em quyết data vậy
ở thời sự phải có cái cụ mày đi kèm nữa
thì mày không thể truyền được cái file
ảnh lên
ở đâu ạ đái
ở
kiểu ngày nữa cơ thì mới chuyển được
file lên đấy ở
đây 7 vừa rồi để tổng hợp của việc
tổng hợp của những cái có thể Điền ở
trong phone anh đứng ở Tí tôi sẽ có bài
tập về cho mấy ông dễ hình dung lại méo
làm những cái bài này chuyện thì cái
lọng đơn giản thôi Nó là kiểu điên những
cái gì Thôi ra những cái mình đã điên
thế thôi mà đúng không ạ
em không có thể nhanh phết nhỉ 8 rưỡi
cũng xong hết toàn bộ những cái hôm hôm
nay học rồi Nếu mà tiếp theo là bây giờ
mình sẽ
cô dạy qua các bạn về à hồ sơ đồ khối sơ
đồ khối
Thực ra là cái sơ đồ khối là đáng lẽ là
thường là hồi mình dạy học đấy thì sơ đồ
khối mình phải học trước cả hồi học thế
nào ngôn ngữ lập trình cơ sơ đồ khối
thuật toán để làm gì để các bạn hình
dung rõ hơn về cái việc đó thế nào là
trình
họ
lập trình bệnh là thơ ca giải quyết
những cái giải quyết những cái mà kiểu
bất bất kỳ cái gì mất cái gì gỗ trong
cuộc sống này thay bị bê Bây giờ tôi
thường hay ví dụ cho sinh viên kiểu như
thế này đó là kiểu Hòa
Tôi thường này bảo sinh viên hãy nói các
bước để mà
mày em ra lấy cốc nước chẳng hạn thì
Ê
mấy ông ca không cần phải nghĩ nhiều về
cái việc đấy nữa thì mày ông cậu bây giờ
chắc là không nào cũng lỗi là không nghĩ
việc lấy nước như thế nào nó ạ đâu chỉ
đứng dậy mà lấy thôi đấy mấy ông từ đó
đơn giản như thế Thực ra đối với với máy
tính thì nó sẽ không có kiểu nó không có
trí tuệ mình sẽ phải ra lệnh cho nó từng
câu lệnh 1 để nó làm từng hành động một
để mà lấy để mà
gì để mà làm từng bước từng bước gọn
[âm nhạc]
thì thì thấy cái số cái để nó từng bước
từng bước ấy thường là ví dụ để mà lấy
cấm nước xem ạ này có nước nhé
bản chất là bước 1 thì sẽ là cậu
ý là đứng dậy làm trà sử các bạn đang
đầu tiên là kiểm tra có đang ngồi không
dám ngồi không đúng ạ Nếu có thì có thì
đứng dậy
lấy kiểu kiện như thế còn nếu đứng sẵn
rồi đi Thôi đủ rồi sau đó thì
xong rồi xác định là xác định bình nước
ở góc nào đúng ạ Để để quay về góc đấy
đúng không ạ Đấy sự chọn khi mà xác định
đồ rồi thì mới bắt đầu kiểu bước bữa đi
được ạ
sau bước đi bước từng bước một đúng ạ
đấy Kiểu thế rồi Cái quan trọng là bước
đi là xong rồi cứ bước từng bước rồi ông
lại phải kiểm tra lại việc lắm
ý
là có chướng ngại vật nào không
tẩy mình tí con chó sủa mèo ú
anh alo
Có chó mình Sủa con mèo hàng xóm mà mèo
hàng xóm thì nó Cứ thỉnh thoảng qua đòi
ăn
à mà nhà mình thì thích nuôi chó mèo
thấy là nó cũng Arsenal nên lại cho nó
nếu mà đi rằng nó nó quen vui rồi lại
qua nhiều quá nhiều thì chó sủa đánh đấy
một phòng học được ổn Đấy
ở
thời tiếp theo nhá
Khi mình bước đi mình sẽ phải luôn xác
nhận lại luôn kiểm tra lại kiểm tra xem
có chướng ngại vật này không nào ạ
và và nếu mà có chướng ngại vật thì mình
lại phải mẹ Nó đứng ở chỗ phải hoặc tui
cất nhắc có ông thì kiểu còn kiểm tra
xem là chứng lại vật đấy có càng trở nhớ
hay không Nếu mà nếu mà nhiều thì mình
có nếu mà cảm thể nhiều thì mình mới Bé
nó còn không thì mình cứ đâm đầu mà nó
không mình nhảy qua Vân Vân Vân chúng nó
có rất nhiều cách đấy thì thì toàn bộ
những người đấy Thực ra là não mình Bây
giờ
mình đủ phát triển này Mà mình xử lý ra
đấy trong vòng vài giây rồi mà mình
không ở phải nghĩ nhiều rồi cái việc đấy
Mình chỉ làm mình hứng lên lấy cốc nước
thì mình đấy thôi đúng ạ đấy Nhưng mà
đối với máy tính thì mình sẽ phải phải
ghi cụ thể từng từng bước từng bước ra
một mình thiếu ở nước nào mà tự nhiên có
một cái vấn đề gì đó dầu tự nhiên có
chướng ngại vật ông ông mỗi cứ cắm đầu
cho cái robot để cứ cắm đầu đi thôi chả
bạn vẫn tự nhiên có cái trứng này vật ở
đằng trước nó không lường được nó tém
hai cái thứ lúc đấy nó làm sao bước đi
nữa đúng ạ Đấy thì méo mà càng kiểm tra
những cái đấy thì thì thì con robot của
ông có vẻ càng ngon càng tốt đúng ạ Làm
lập trình bản chất nó là như thế thôi đó
là cá tính hết trước tất cả các trường
hợp sau đó thì ghi ra cho máy tính để
máy tính tự lường thế thôi à à
Ừ ok
mô
hình ảnh
Ừ
Ok thì bây giờ mình sẽ thử
đầu tiên là cho các bạn xem lại về Cái
cái sơ đồ mà hôm trước mình có có cái
ảnh ấy và đây được sơ đồ khối thuật toán
đi mình có lẽ ảnh ông trước nó cũng
tương đối rồi
Ừ để các bạn hình dung về những cái hình
này này
những cái hình mà các bạn thường phải có
ở trong cái sơ đồ khối
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ thử chỉ các bạn vẽ
một cái thứ gì đó được bọn
Ê
[âm nhạc]
mấy ông thường ai lên có thể lên cái
trang dro.io Tôi tưởng ai dùng này để mà
vẽ sơ đồ toán này hãy thậm chí sơ đồ hồ
sơ đồ cơ sở liệu 2 sơ đồ trực thể tội
thì phải vẽ trên này à
ở tạm cái cháu lên
ừ ừ
ở
đầu tiên thì các bạn sẽ phải luôn có cái
bắt đầu và kết thúc phải biết đồ lúc mà
bắt đầu lúc nào kết thúc của một cái
chương trình được ạ thì nó Hình hình này
hình bắt đầu rồi không ạ thử thưởng
thường sẽ có phải bị ghi và e này à
a beginner ngắm cái sẽ là em chẳng hạn
đúng ạ chiều kiểu ngay
sau đó thì mày không thể biết mấy cái
bất kỳ đúng không ạ
[âm nhạc]
Nếu có thể viết là kiểu chuyện tình của
đời ông nó sẽ như nào sẽ một vòng luẩn
quẩn như thế nào trả lại
Đợi tí nha cho con mèo An Phát đã hai
phút hạnh phúc à
à à
ừ ừ
anh alo alo alo em mèo trên 18 tuổi
đi shopping
à à
Ừ
ông kia đang ghi từng bước thôi
quá trình cho mèo ăn
con mèo đấy nó còn ăn thức ăn cho chó cơ
đẩy cái gì nấu ăn có con chó là tôi có
vẻ không chịu ăn hạt
Vì thế nên là mua cái hạt có tiền lãi
rồi cùng bây giờ cho mèo hàng xóm ăn
Ok thôi quay lại này Đầu tiên thì giờ
sửa tôi được Cứ thử mô tả qua cái cái
cuộc tinh của đa số mấy ông đi ông ạ
Không biết có động chạm gì không nhưng
đại khái là cậu mục tiêu lúc đầu Giả sử
một tiếng lúc đầu là kẻ o o
Ừ Tôi muốn tìm bạn gái ạ đúng ạ ta sẽ
được
cái nhập này là để người dùng nhập vào
nhá á
chứ không phải nhập lương mép màn anh
nhá cái cái xử lý tính toán này đôi khi
là nó sẽ là để mà hiển thị ra nữa
Ừ hai cái đôi khi bị nhầm đấy thử cả hai
này nói cuộc chung lại được thì chị gia
này dễ hiển thị là là sự nó bao gồm một
câu nói là nó được Kiều Tôi
muốn có người yêu Dạ
anh kể nha và đương nhiên là nổi đến
chiều ngày không ạ
tổ tiếp thế nào ạ
anh em luôn đi lại mưa
tiếp tiếp theo là kiểu đi tìm đúng không
ạ Đi tìm là hành động hành động này sẽ
là xử lý nó sẽ là hình
thực ra là cái này thì nó hơi say Vậy
phải mình xem mặt tí những cái xử lý nó
hình bình hành cơ
xem nhé
AE nhập nọ
sản xuất ra kết quả sâu ra kết quả của
đội hình bình hành Châu Huệ sai sai
Ừ vậy để xem lại đã lâu lắm rồi không
động cái này
Ẩm Thực ra là chỉ làm với mức tương đối
thôi mình mình không rõ được là cái hồi
của mình học đúng đây cái xử lý mà sẽ
giải hình này bao gồm các xử lý
xe tải cứ ghi ngay
ý là kiếm yêu trở lại à
ừ ừ
chỉ có như thế này sau đó thì
tìm được chưa đúng không
cái cái câu điều kiện này các bạn phải
luôn nhớ nhé câu điều kiện này nó sẽ gần
như chị trả về chua phone thôi mình mình
không làm đi có xích cay cậu là kiểm tra
với nó ra được rất nhiều kết quả không
mình nên chỉ trả về chua phô nó chuẩn
tay giờ sửa là tìm được chưa Nếu mà chưa
thì mình mình sẽ có hai cái ở đây không
ạ Mình sẽ có cái ở đây
ở
trường hợp đúng ở trường hợp sai đi
ở tại đại minh tinh ý
à à
xe tải
ăn canh cái nổi nó hơi bị
khi tách Ok Lúc nãy giờ chồng có phải
thân cần một tí thôi
xe tải mình sẽ ra
Có không đó chỉ có không thôi
Đúng Sai sai cả
sai thì quay lại tìm người yêu đúng ạ
Nếu mà đúng thì sao
Ê mấy ông cãi nhau gì ở kia vậy
Ừ nếu mà đúng thì
nhà mình có thể kiểm tra tiếp từ Google
sử gặp
họ có chấp nhận mình không họ có yêu lại
mình không đúng mà Vân Vân Vân họ có phù
hợp không đâu ạ Họ phù hợp không hiểu
lại ạ
khi tìm được phát quê luôn
cái kiểu thế đúng không ạ thì nó lại có
xảy ra 2 trường hợp nữa đúng ạ Nếu mà
giờ xử sai thì lại quay lại tìm không ạ
cứ thế
xe
tải Nếu mà say được ạ
à à
ở mấy cái này mấy ông nhìn dễ hiểu mà
không ạ
Ừ đúng vậy
mà nếu mà
anh không em thường ta có thể có nhiều
cái trường hợp đúng ạ
[âm nhạc]
Đã họ có phù hợp không Nếu mà đúng thì
sẽ là kiểu giả sự là
áo cưới đủ ạ đại khái Thế mình có thể ở
đây chốt một cái to đùng ở đây là
Áo
Cưới Sau đó kết thúc mọi cuộc đời Kiệt
mã kiểu gì thế
anh như này những bài toán ở đây mấy ông
thấy thời gian vòng lặp kiểu này là
không đúng là không tốt Vậy sao Bởi vì
nếu nếu mà kiểu bé ông nghĩ trường hợp
là thứ nhất là kết quả chung quy trở lại
có mỗi cưới không ổn đúng không ạ
về cuộc đời của mấy ông chắc hổ khi quay
quần đi quay quần lại kịp với yêu
em mãi là không nên thời đại khái thế
hoặc à Mấy ông chỉ cần kiếm kiếm đến
khoảng tầm ba bốn lần ở mấy ông đã chán
rồi nếu không một kiếm nữa mày ông muốn
độc thân luôn thì sao Đúng rồi thì miếng
sẽ phải kiểm tra thêm điều kiện ở đây
nữa là kiểm tra là là nếu mà nó ba lần
rồi chẳng ạ
ba bốn lần rồi ba bốn lần mà hạch liên
tiếp thì mới ông sẽ có thể cho ra kết
quả đấy luôn đúng ạ Là là kiểu độc thân
thì đại khái Thế đây để tôi thử sửa lại
cái này nhé
đẩy cái này lên trên cho mấy ông mình để
sửa đây ạ khi sex
à à
ừ ừ
ở
thời tiết đầu tiên là vẫn quay lại kiếm
người yêu thì lần này mình sẽ là
đề kiểm tra
Ừ đợi thế nó sẽ không quay hận về đây
nữa
à
mà nó sẽ có thêm một bước kiểm tra đây
nữa là
Ừ kiểu như này
em kiếm mấy lần rồi trả lại
à Đủ ba lần chưa học đủ ba lần kiếm chưa
cả tự nhiên lúc đầu là chưa thì sẽ là
kiếm thôi
ừ ừ
hỗ trợ đi rồi chồng trò nói chồng chồng
đẹp đẹp một tí
à à
ừ ừ
ở
trong trường hợp
a b trong trường hợp nếu mà sai thì mình
có hạnh kiểm tiếp Còn nếu mà đúng thì
sao Nếu mà đúng thì mình sẽ là nhảy đến
một cái gì đó nó ạ Mình sẽ nhảy đến cái
à
Ê độc thân thôi trở lại
cái sau đó thì cũng nghề để kệ em ạ
khi về ông đừng chọn ngã rẽ này nhé
à à
cô gái méo hoàn toàn có thể làm như thế
này à
Ừ cái này Thực ra là nó bị Hơi bị lỗi
còn là nhìn cho khỏe hơi khó đã lẽ cái
đoạn này của tôi làm kiểu chéo chéo hợp
lý hơn sự lại một tí
à à
ừ ừ
Ừ nó kiểu chấm như thế này ok rồi đấy ạ
ở đó đây đây đây là một cái sơ đồ khối
rồi các bạn sẽ Hình dung là nó sẽ vòng
lặp kiểu như hai nó sẽ kiểm tra theo
thành công theo thất bại và từ từ nghệ
thường là mấy ông sẽ làm cái sơ đồ khối
hoặc gặp mã Dạ như thế này trước sau đó
mới ông ấy nhảy sang cốt Nếu không phải
từ cái sơ đồ khối này sẽ sinh ra mã ra ở
đây sẽ kéo là lúc đầu sẽ xử lý như thế
nào in ra cái gì sau đó thì lên vòng lọc
khoai điểm còn for gì đó đúng không ạ
Đấy
Vì sao sau đó thì mày ông làm tiếp chọn
nhưng mà luôn nhớ là phải có big in và
em hai cái này nó thể hai kết thúc khác
nhau Tôi không nói kế hút vào nó có hậu
hơn nhưng kiểu gì cũng sẽ phải lùn AD
nhé Nếu ông không quay lại nối tivi nói
nhá Không không có chửi ở trường quay
lại bình yên Đây nhá không có Nó quay
lại được đến đây thôi cái kiểu thế
có kháng thể có thể không phải đủ ba lần
kiếm chưa có thể đủ 30 tuổi chưa rằng
lại đủ ví dụ đủ 70 tuổi này rồi mày
không sẽ ra đủ 70 chưa đúng không ạ
Nếu mà chưa đủ 70 thì vẫn còn chinh
chiến tiếp Còn nếu mà đủ rồi thôi an
phận độc thân
Ừ nếu không chạy mặt mình tắt 70 tuổi
vẫn chưa kiếm được béo cũng nên cứng
nhắc lại đấy
Ok thế này đủ dễ hiểu cho mấy ông qua về
cái sơ đồ khối chưa và từ đây mày ông sẽ
ngồi làm bài tập tiếp của tôi nhá
mọi người Chắc hết rồi
à Bố mày sẽ ra dạy qua như thế để buổi
sau mình sẽ khá là nhiều khá nhiều bạch
tập cũng như kiến thức vì nó sẽ mới hơn
khá nhiều
ở Hà Nội mua chị cách nộp bài cốt bằng
pp đúng không Thế là các bạn đăng lên Ít
hấp thôi các bạn đăng ký hấp
là được nhưng mà mỗi tội là không chạy
trực tiếp trên đấy các bạn đăng ký hát
và gửi cho mình link biết hát về mình
xem thôi nhọn tạo Zippo trên này sau đó
thì tăng đang cốt lên bình thường mà gửi
cho mình cái link của cái Zippo đấy là
được đóng bạn gửi mình depot kiểu như
này anh mình sẽ Xem cốt được trên này là
được mà nó không ạ Thực ra là bài tập
này thì à
em vẫn chưa đến mức là khó lỗi cần phải
Chữ Lắm những cái buổi sau nữa cơ thì
chắc Sào Nam mỗi bạn sẽ làm Nếu hiểu
riêng mà lúc đấy mình sẽ
mình sẽ phải chữa cũng thể tưởng bạn sau
đây
Ừ ok các bạn còn thắc mắc gì nữa không ạ
Không thì mình sẽ kết thúc sớm buổi hôm
nay rồi mình sẽ gửi các bạn cái phone
này các bạn đăng ký
đăng ký để mà theo cặp nhé làm việc theo
cặp
từ từ mày ông ở đây Sao mày không cũng
đang mong ông nào sẽ
chị sẽ vào nhóm với bạn Phương Linh trả
lại mấy bạn nữ từ Thế nếu không vào nhóm
mấy bạn đấy thì phải rảnh mình vẫn đấy
nhé Đừng để dành lại nhé nó hơi bị thản
thương tí ý
à à
Ồ không tôi không khuyến khích mẹo làm
nhỏ một người lại nhóm những nên làm
kiểu tập thể một tí để mà mình quen với
việc làm Đồng Đội
à à
Ý mình là không nên kiểu làm cá nhân bởi
vì đi làm thì mình cũng làm có tập thể
mình có quen việc à Bởi vì làm tập thể
đấy còn việc lạ đầy cốt cho nhau như nào
ra việc nhau như nào có dư thứ nó sẽ hợp
lý hơn ở muốn cho thân à à
nghe có phần góp ý ai bạn nằm trong cái
pho mày có góp ý cũng được được được
được thì mình xem lại các bạn muốn nhắn
nhủ cái gì nữa không ạ nhắn nhủ có thể
không phải nhắn nhủ có thể nhắn gửi cho
mình hòa nhắn nhủ là kiểu là kiểu em
muốn tìm bạn kiểu cao to đen hôi ẩn các
thứ tư nữa thì thôi còn sắp xếp trả nặng
thế lúc bạn
anh không Bạn nào Nói chung là bạn nào
mà muốn bảo vệ đoán Muốn Nói chung là
bây giờ nó vẫn là trên tinh thần tượng
biện mà Mấy ông thực sự muốn thành công
thì mày không phải cũng tự tin lên rồi
Mày Ông cũng sẽ phải tham gia đêm Lúc
đầu bây giờ sẽ sáng là
tôi không hướng đến cho những cái bạn mà
giỏi sẵn rồi Tôi đang hướng đến những
cái ông mà chưa biết thì gì méo vẫn sẵn
sàng và tham gia vào vì mình không mất
cái gì cả quan trọng mình không mất gì
cả đúng để bà cậu mình sẽ học hỏi và
mình sẽ tự cố gắng thấy mình còn thiếu
cái gì và thấy các bạn kia cũng giỏi như
nào thì mình sẽ càng phải biết phấn đấu
đúng không ạ Chứ mấy ông ở cơ bảo theo
kiểu theo kiểu bị tự ti và nhược trí
theo kiểu là em sợ vào làm tại cho các
bạn đấy hay gì đó em thấy các bạn đấy
Giỏi quá Vân khi thế là chết rồi Thế là
con ngựa các bạn đấy khi bé luôn thiếu
nhân lực kéo là toàn những ngày ông Giỏi
vãi chưởng hoặc là những chảo rán đi làm
đã
dọn nên làm nếu cứ họ thỏa mãn đăng ký
có số thứ không sao đâu
anh và tôi tôi thì tuy nhiên là khi mà
tôi chấm đồ án cũng như là khi mà tôi
kiểm tra Sở sẽ có kiểm tra
[âm nhạc]
tôi kiểm tra tiến trình các bạn đấy thì
tôi sẽ
khi cha cũng dễ hả
khắt khe một tí
bởi vì nó Tôi sẽ cho mấy ông này hình
dung việc thì đi làm nó sẽ như nào các
thứ thuốc
lưu này này ổn không Lúc này này chắc
lại nó hấp dẫn so với khá nhiều ngày mấy
giờ đấy ạ
à
Tôi đang nghĩ là không biết cái form nó
sẽ điền những cái gì đây còn nhiều nữa à
anh béo ở đây tranh thủ khi gợi ý trước
luôn cho tôi đi là do mày cần phải điện
lại cái gì tôi đang định là để cho link
Facebook ở đây để để mà tôi sẽ không hẳn
kết bạn rồi tôi sẽ nhắn tin với mấy bạn
đấy Tôi sẽ tạo nhóm chat cho mấy ông này
mấy ông chat
anh có thể một cách anh như thế Tôi đang
chẳng biết cũng đang hơi bị loạn nó đấy
ừ ừ
a form đăng ký
làm đồ ăn
từ giải fake a
Anh
Hạnh for này chắc là sẽ là mình sẽ chốt
đến chủ nhật tuần sau nhé mình sẽ bóng
đóng form vào cuối tuần sau để mà bề để
mà mình chốt những ngày sau đó mình sẽ
random những ai vào nhóm nào cũng thương
rồi à
à à
cho tôi cho mấy ông Linh facebook hay
các thứ thứ rồi mấy ông có gì tự liên
lạc bằng cách khác sau đó ạ
ngày à
hai năm nữa
ừ ừ
à à
ở đầu tiên thì tôi bắt mày không phải
có phải có cái vụ thì được phép điện một
lần đấy tránh mấy ông Tommy
bộ phim sex hay Điền email này
có
link Facebook của bạn rồi được à
[âm nhạc]
em có nên tí nữa à
anh góp ý À có tí hoặc
Đi học vui hoa cà bạn kia ở nói nó sẽ ra
chỗ ghi chú thêm ạ
dùng từ ghi chú ổn nó nhỉ Tự nhiên tôi
giúp ăn quá
Xin Kiểu đại khái Tôi muốn cho mấy bạn
này có thể ghi thêm các chú thích gì gì
đó
à à
Anh hiểu đế tệ bạn đấy kiệu sạch sữa là
kéo em chỉ muốn với bạn nữ em chỉ hướng
muốn với bạn nam đại khái thế tôi nói
thế mày không không được mấy ông đi cái
đấy vào thôi không quan tâm nhé Tôi sẽ
luôn đấy
Anh tên this code không tặng bộ qua mấy
cái yếu tố this code các thứ thứ
Facebook về mẹ Đông nhiều người dùng
nhất để cho thế thôi
ở mấy cái giới tính có tình trạng hôn
nhân lại vân vân thì mấy ông từ link
Facebook của mình tự biết nhé để họ ok
em có nên gì nhỉ
anh gửi cho thế rồi có mỗi hai cái này
thôi ông ạ
ừ ừ
Ừ Ok chờ tí rồi gửi cho mấy ông cái link
này mẹo làm luôn
ở trình độ trình độ máy em sẽ tự tự biết
nhau trình độ nha thôi ông ạ
Nếu mà nhóm yếu thì được là năm yếu thì
làm cái máy quét đơn giản thôi cũng được
mà đúng ạ Chúng ta sẽ khô cố gắng làm
cái gì đó thôi chúng ta không cần việc
so sánh mình với bất kỳ ai như tôi từng
nói nó kiểu ông kia với người có nhiều
người ta lương cao lương của mình chỉ
cần mức tương đối là được không ạ
à à
Ừ
ok Nói cho đại khái như thế à
Ẩm Thực ra là có nhớ bạn ở đây ví dụ bạn
kia bảo nó không thích làm theo nhóm
hoặc là thận Thế là các bạn còn bị hứng
Nội kiểu không quen làm việc theo nhóm
cũng như là không mà bảo vệ đồ án được
vân vân thì cái này được hơi khó vì đi
làm thực tế các bạn cầu gì cũng sẽ phải
gặp thôi Thế là tôi đang hướng đến cùng
đến cho các bạn có quen được kiểu môi
trường đi làm được họ sẽ có những cái
khắt khe có những cái bắt buộc phải là
không phải vì thiếu cái gì là được nhưng
mà đỡ như là tôi cũng sẽ không yêu cầu
quá gắt hẹn gặp người mấy bọn đấy bắt
mấy bạn đấy phải trong ngày nào nói
chuyện với bạn kia hai cái gì đó Nói
chung là mấy ông có phải tự sắp xếp với
nhau đúng không ạ quen được việc có thêm
một đồng nghiệp đi đúng ạ
ừ ừ
Em không quen làm việc theo nhóm ở nhiên
bây giờ phải quen em thôi ạ đúng không ạ
chẳng ai lúc đầu quen cả Và thậm chí A
quen rồi có thể con ghét cứ hỏi quen rồi
thích tôi đã từng khẳng định với nhiều
sinh viên của tôi đó là rất nhờ bạn
nhiều bạn là bạn thân thật chứ người yêu
bạn nhỏ hẳn hoi nhé Làm cùng chung đồ án
xong chia tay
tôi không lạ gì những cái trường hợp với
cả tôi không Tôi không
vì nó không bảo là mày ông cậu làm xong
sẽ thân nhau cái gì đó nó chỉ nói là
quen với việc đấy nhà thiệu về sau đi
làm Mẹ không được chọn đồng nghiệp đâu
trừ khi ông trước khi ông một con sếp
không ạ Thôi bây giờ nói chúng lại khá
như thế mày ông tôi từ trước này tôi dậy
sinh viên nó cũng là như thế sẽ Hai
người cùng một nhóm A
Ừ nếu mà lẻ ông nào ra thì tôi sẽ xem
sex không ạ nhưng mà này sẽ chỉ là một
ông mà chị có chuyện này hay ông 23 ông
gì đấy không ạ Thôi Phạm Huy nhé
Thế thôi Gửi cái link này sẽ gửi link
này cho mấy ông ở bình luận của video
này sau nhé
à à
số karaoke tạm bộ Hôm nay chắc là thế
thôi chào nhé